I wait a minute like to propose a toast
to my family someday soon you're gonna
have families of your own and if you're
lucky you remember the little moments
like this now we're good
Cheers
Oh
I never stopped to worry bout a thing
open
this depression
it's so good hey buddies this is steve
Simone I'm hanging out with my pal mr.
lease hi hat hi Steve and you're
listening to good times with Steve
Simone we just got done hanging out with
mods that was fun huh it was oh my God
he's it's always nice cuz I I had no
known of mozz I'm I could be saying
along Friday movie whatever fighting
movie he was in mmm like that was you
came out probably in high school maybe
beginning of college I doubt it but it
was hysterical and it's always that does
the second time I've gotten to meet him
and it's always nice when someone like
that he's so nice yeah yeah he's so cool
I'm so happy that we had him on here oh
yeah I ran into cuz yesterday I flew
back from indy and he was on my shuttle
back to the parking lot yeah that's Boz
and then he was tell me about his new
movie and I was like wait come on good
times to promote it and it's perfect
because he's like a such a good person
I've as a guest too oh yeah I mean he's
he's he's a very popular especially it's
always it's interesting and we talked
about it on the episode of him just the
amount of what he means to Iranian
audiences yeah it's how how huge and
popular he is and how he's like a like a
spokesperson for an entire I'm glad
waste or whatever you want to say but
well it's like nationality I think it's
just really cool and we talked about we
hit on this a little bit but then you
and I talked about it soon as mas left
that's usually like how every light
because it's like the like you always
think of stuff you should have said
afterwards right yeah but it's like how
cool is that that he's now that example
that he didn't have when he was eight
years old or nine years old you know
he's like super cool funny dude yeah it
must be it must be kind of trippy to
look back on it and still see yourself
as a eight or nine year old and then now
he just made a movie that's cool yeah
awesome so how was in d wonderful I was
up guys I'm so thankful to all you guys
that came out and traveled so far Lee
there was people that drove from Peoria
from Chicago one guy drove all the way
from Oklahoma was like over 10 hours
another couple came all the way from
they brought me cheesecake too came all
the way from
Michigan neoliberal drove all like they
made a hike to come hang and so nice of
them yeah and then my buddy Peyton she
drew me the best picture ever and I
think I might turn him into a TV t-shirt
you might have that was a pretty great
picture yeah for good times for that and
then you got a keg shake which is
amazing yes the best i'm jung ji sub
jealous look at those kegs are plus i
ate at UM steak and shake when i was
there i was so delicious whenever I go
to the Midwest ated steak and shake
because when i first went on tours Pauly
Shore like 15 years ago he said he would
he brought me to the Midwest and it was
like that was the first tour Sam Kinison
brought him on and he said as soon as
Sam Kinison got to the Midwest he'd go
to steak and shake so that's what we
always did so now whenever I'm in the
Midwest I always go to steak and shake
their starting a tradition looking one
from Kennison the poly domain that's
really fun yeah do you think about it
every time we didn't look oh yes cuz I
yeah for sure I do how old were you when
you went with Paula do you remember I
was like your age wow that's pretty
great at the beginning of comedy yeah I
first started just selling his t-shirts
on the road he wouldn't let me do comedy
really yeah he was just be like you
could sell the shirts I was like
okeydoke just to be there to be involved
yeah and speaking of it you're gonna be
on the road with him soon oh yeah the
weekend this comes out oh cool ok and
then uh yeah I think if we get will
release this early on sunday so anybody
listening can come to the shows in
Tacoma and then like the 18th through
the 22nd I'm gonna be at in Edmonton
very cool that's going to be awesome so
yeah so we're gonna do shows wednesday
through sunday night in Edmonton and
then I guess it'll be wednesday the 25th
they're telling me I'm going to tape a
season 3 of this is not happening for
Comedy Central so if you guys want
tickets to see that I'm going to do the
Wednesday night show the second show
second show Wednesday on the
twenty-fifth I don't want to make sure
all you guys are there because you were
there last year
and made me do so much better I wasn't
nervous because I knew I knew so many
people in the audience feel like hey
buddy I was like there's my pals it
makes it easier you know just hanging
out with your buddies yeah that's gonna
be fun so that's two seasons in a row
okay if you haven't been to see that
show live it's a lot different than the
and not that the TV show version is is
bad but it's just different because it's
not it's not the same lineup you're
gonna see that on the show and then you
get to see the full [__] oh and that's
the other thing the full version of my
story just came out on youtube oh cool
yeah so it's out there guys the one I
told on season two of this is not
happening so that's the coolest thing
that re does make sure that the best
version of that gets because that's
where really everybody's going to watch
it anyways YouTube right a lot of people
in its it's just a longer version of it
so it's a they don't have to cut out any
of the stuff for time and since the way
I wanted it to be yeah it's really
really fun yeah so that's going to be on
Wednesday the 25th on Thursday the 26
we're doing a fundraiser at the comedy
store for regular hero to support all
the work we do with the kids it's not
set in stone but I'm gonna let you guys
know it looks like we're going to gain
cooking bill burr co-headline well yeah
we're gonna have to huge comics and that
would be thursday the 26 I've friends
that are friends with those guys so it's
only gonna be a twenty dollar ticket
tell your friends go online get tickets
for the 26th and then uh like I said
Edmonton it'll be the 18th through the
22nd it Rick Bronson's comedy club and
at the mall right there on hadn't
intended very excited a lot of good
stuffs happening and then soon as I'm in
town in June I'll start coming out with
good times every week buddies I'm sorry
that we're doing every other week but
I'm just so busy and that's a good thing
though yeah that's the whole point
mm-hmm all right let's get into this
episode with mods and then we'll come
back with our gratitude list give a
shout out to some of our sponsors and
that's it
cuz the mics work now mm-hmm awesome and
I will do an intro later you know it
just was just do it thank you so much
for being here thank you for having me
man I was so happy to see you yesterday
that was like a perfect random moment I
was like I think it might be Maz yeah
and then I did that creepy thing I was
trying to look under your hat it's like
this and i was like it is maaz it is
much I think we're all so at least I am
with my with my head in the in my phone
then heads down you can't see anybody
yeah plus you had your hat like perfect
celebrity style oh you couldn't really
see her face oh this is how it fits my
head was made to be a celebrity at the
rest of my buddies catching up so
speaking of celebrities you have a new
film out yeah man I got a film out it's
called Jimmy vest food American Hero
awesome and the reason it's best food is
because he lives in Westwood yes but
Iranians can't pronounce their w so they
say V instead of W so it's vest food
that's awesome Jimmy vest with American
here I described it as the Persian Pink
Panther meets Bharat oh my gosh that's
how just right there you got me hooked
yeah it's a silly over the top comedy
it's um about this guy in Iran who loves
America and he loves American movies and
he loves Steve McQueen from the movie
Bullitt fantastical he wants to be a cop
it was ok let's move to America be a
cool cop like McQueen was but who
doesn't been sauces that's fantastic
right and so he was the green card
lottery to come to America there's
actually is such a thing Wow yeah so he
was a green card lottery the beginning
movie to come to America and once he
gets here he thinks he's going to be you
know a cop but then once he gets America
realizes that you know 21st century
America is not not the bullet years and
he not as embracing as it used to be wow
so he ends up with a job working as a
security guard a person grocery store
that's awesome and then somehow he
stumbles his way into this plot to start
World War three he's got to save the
world from there that is awesome so it's
this uh it's this fun silly comedy the
tagline is heroes aren't born they're
imported oh that's hilarious yeah and I
wanted to you know since
running American I've always wanted to
was I always wanted to do like a Peter
Sellers e-type Pink Panther movie Peter
Sellers genius Balian Catherine being
there like that level of comedy he
worked on so many different levels yeah
and I think silly comedy when it's done
right yeah is the funniest great it's
such a difficult balance it is if it is
a two broad it's not funny yeah if it's
not silly enough it's like what are you
doing it like when you can hit that note
ah it buckled me yeah it was it was uh
it is he right yet we had a lot of stuff
that we shot that I thought oh this
could be amazing we saw it and in the
Edit I was like God doesn't quite work
out like he's like we just said it's if
it's off a little bit yeah so but but we
came up with I think a fun silly movie
we actually got into the Austin Film
Festival well that's cool yeah we won we
won the Best Comedy jury as well as
audience oh my gosh it's incredible good
man some good stuff it soaks come is
finally coming out I feel like I come in
and out with the sound I don't know
those are fine okay and so I might just
be our headphones yeah so so we finally
come out friday the 13th Oh fantastic
what cities la encino Irvine and DC
fantastic and then after that we're
gonna come out on the 20th in New York
and Toronto awesome and then on the
twenty-ninth we're gonna have a
screening in San Francisco couple of
screenings in San Francisco you know
it's a struggle is a very independent
movie so we we had to raise the money i
co-wrote it wow she directed as well I
know i co-produced it I started it the
director was a guy named Jonathan
kesselman who directed a movie called
the hebrew hammer which was an amazing
movie no hebrew hammer was another silly
kind of it was a with the the kid from
mom Goldberg's yeah Jonathan something
made a nut job yeah exactly I know
exactly I remember seeing that thang
about a couple years ago yeah and it was
it's a silly comedy and I'm and I got me
curious with the guys name is it's a
great movie you would love it it's like
a Jewish superhero it's got exactly
exactly mrs. hebrew hammer did you get
the megan brother's involved to promote
in toronto you know they're going to the
other great but that's nice ever those
guys are great right Adam Goldberg the
atom or yes yeah so it was a silly you
know it's a cult
cult hit it's got its own following
you've been working on this character
for a long time though yes so what
happened was there was a play a friend
of mine the guy who co-wrote this his
name is a mural Hep C and he had done
play he'd written a play that we did in
the like mid 90s okay where it was
called the bay lined date hilarious
blind date with a Persian accent yes and
it was about a guy who goes on a blind
date with this girl the guy's a total
Charlotte's and he's pretending to have
all this money doesn't have it yeah and
the girls a gold digger so she's falling
for it yeah that's the perfect for each
other and so in the middle of the play
the guy at some point trying to be cool
he's like you know my name is jamshid
that's that's a Persian name jamshid
how's my name is he goes my name is Jim
cheetah but you can call me Jimmy Carr
fanned and so from there I told him once
we stopped in the play a few years later
I said hey man remember that the play we
did I said I feel like that character
can be in a movie like we should do a
movie around it so he and i just started
loosely writing probably about 10 years
ago Wow on and off on and off then we
got like I mean just this is independent
movies you know it's amazing because how
many times you sit around with a friend
and go hey man you'll be granted in for
a movie is that it up yes and then you
got to execute the script it's so much
work which is an uphill battle itself
yeah just taking it from your brain onto
the page it's it's so challenge it's so
far for me as a writer it's very
frustrating because I can see it but I
can't necessarily translate yeah most of
us have an idea of a scene yes or an
idea that like you know you're like oh
it's a guy who the whole world is ended
and there's one guy left yeah that's a
cool idea now you go wait a minute
what's the story yeah what's the story
that's like one minute like yeah it's a
struggle what's going what does he want
what yeah it's it's then you write it
and you go I like this is good and then
you go negative negative make it yeah
and who's gonna just come out and make
your movie nobody mmm so you got to go
raise the money Wow so we had like in
2008 2007 when we were doing the axis of
evil comedy tour yeah we um we were in
the middle east and was this guy who was
like I want to work with you on
something I'm my own investigate I'm in
so then I came back to the US this
wasn't due by the guy was in dubai okay
came back to America we got on a call
with him and the law
is all this stuff to like get the money
and let's make it happen yeah and then
like a couple months later he's like ah
you know the stock market crashed I
can't really do this like uh-uh so he
fell through then this other dude comes
around he's like I got the biggest
roofing company on the East Coast Wow I
want to do it he's goes I've been doing
like black films and I want to do your
film why I was a Persian guy I got some
yeah he falls through oh god this is not
easy so then we were just kind of
lingering and then finally my co-writer
it was like at some point so we just got
to do this man yeah so we did we did a
Kickstarter with an IndieGoGo campaign
indigo Boston yeah and this was in 2012
i think with the indiegogo campaign and
here's a crazy part of that is at the
time I had like maybe a hundred and
hundred and like 930 40,000 fans on
Facebook yeah we thought hey we'll put
will put on facebook everyone will give
a dollar will have a hundred and thirty
thousand good to go yeah we got our seed
money we can proceed yes we put her on
and then it was like crickets like not
ha and like a few weeks go by and we've
raised like seven thousand dollars and I
told the guy was like my co-writer go we
can't make a movie we could like go
vacation in Mexico Cabo Cabo Wabo for a
couple weeks really livin large and and
then eventually somebody brought to my
attention that there's a lot of
successful Iranian Americans in Silicon
Valley yeah and they said why don't you
try and do a fundraiser with them and
here's a key that to to crowdfunding
okay that I found out afterwards because
I talked to this guy who was
experiencing crowdfunding and he said
the number one thing is he goes don't
rush into it a lot of people think hey I
got a great idea for a project i'll put
it up my friends and family everyone
would give and i'll make the money yeah
doesn't happen okay so this guy was
saying spend a year or whatever it is
getting people ready for your project
tell them go to parties tell people yeah
i got this movie coming out or whatever
it is yeah i got this invention i got
this whatever it is yeah get them to
talk to you listen to you and then get
them to also commit to you yeah to say
yeah you know what I that sounds a good
idea let me know when you do it so you
have all these people lined up and then
he said also in the middle of your
crowdfunding have an event where people
pay a little
money like let's say no me a ticket to a
show or whatever it is like 20 bucks a
they're gonna pay you a hundred bucks
they're gonna come to a party or to a
show or whatever it said something
something cool that ya do whether you
have a friend was a musician or you have
or your your comedian yourself or or
whatever it is or you have a friend as a
cook you know you put it together have
them do that so that it kind of boosts
your numbers a little bit and then if
you have anyone who's got a lot of money
that want they want to put in like let's
say you have a relative was like hey man
I really want to support you want to
give you five grand or whatever have
them either put it early or put it late
cuz it late you're gonna need that final
push gotcha and early it's good to so
that when people go on that page to go
yes gold satin he's got 50 it's doable
let me put the other couple hundred
bucks toward this awesome it's all this
crazy stuff so we basically got we
raised a little over 100 grand from that
whole process that's Fanta
congratulations thanks man was a Mexican
if it was amazing yeah a lot of money
yeah and then from there we were able to
get other people to invest so we got all
the money together and then it's like
you gotta go make it yeah then you gotta
edit it they give me some festivals and
then you think okay p someone is going
to come along and just buy it and
distribute it all right well the problem
there is the big distributors are used
to dealing with big films yes so they
don't want a small budget film they you
know they you know they're used to
spending 20 30 million at least on
advertising and then the smaller
distributors what they do is they
lowball the hell out of you because they
want to just get your product in the
hopes that it might hit if it hits great
they make money you make a little bit of
money yeah if it doesn't hit well then
they've got your movie as part of their
library of movies and then they you know
in the future if they decide to sell the
the company or something to go we got a
thousand you know titles or whatever it
is so as you put in all the work and
then there's these distributors that
want to lowball you like and then that
they just acquire it so all your hard
work they buy it for pennies on the
dollars their goal yeah so what they
have is they have listened they have
some they have expertise because they
know how to get it to certain theaters
have contacts a they know how to get
business their business so you get
excited to go oh great they're gonna get
into theaters and all this other stuff
the other thing that they do sometimes
is
take it and then they will come back to
you and they'll say okay so you know it
costs us fifty thousand dollars to put
the the print ads and all they like that
all this other stuff and basically
everything they're putting out there
they're kind of there they're adding a
little premium to it so just make her
some hey ain't gettin paid half so they
make their money no matter what yeah
you're the one who in the end is like oh
my god like I'm watching all this stuff
come and go no idea and really we just
count on people to go out like if people
go out yes and um and see the stuff for
people want by your special whatever it
is yeah then you can legitimately say
okay this thing made whatever a million
dollars so it made some money and that's
kind of the proof in the pudding gotcha
you know but if people don't go out then
it's just this product that's out there
that you're just hustling to get people
to see from time to time alright so what
we need are my bodies out there that are
listening right now it's going to be an
l a-- it's southern california have
copied you have her vine los angeles ya
allah sizes urban Encino and then
washington DC this friday the 13th okay
friday the 20th its new york and toronto
awesome and then on the twenty-ninth
it's two screenings in san francisco
where i'll be up there at the roxy
theater oh that's great introduce it and
do a Q&A afterwards but all this stuff
is on jimmy vest vidcom so that's just
VES t.v ood Jimmy vest vidcom then go to
show times and they can check out the
trailer there too i do i tell people
check out the trailer if you think it's
funny go see it that's awesome you know
and don't wait cuz like you know we all
are bombarded by so much media nowadays
sure sure myself included I've been
trying to go see that movie Keanu for a
while it looks hilarious haven't seen
that you know we're just how about the
dices show I haven't seen I haven't seen
anything people are so bombarded we
don't have time but a movie like this is
such a small movie that it ain't gonna
hang around too long gotcha suppose I go
see it helped us kind of you know have a
good box office and and I think that I
think they'll have fun enjoy you're a
funny dude so I'm sure anything that you
came from your passion it's gonna be
awesome I can't like this listen I'm
proud of the movie I'm proud of the
movie I'm proud of the actors I've seen
it like a thousand times and i love it
at one time I don't get high that often
yeah but a friend of mine who's a
the stoner showed up on time and had any
yet a little joint so we smoked it and
watched it uh it was hilarious and I
think I know why people do that yes like
this is a stoner movie that's all is
because the characters are so cartoony
an Outland outlandish that I think
people will like you know people will
like it and then also the other thing is
it's got a little bit of a message of
peace nowadays because this you know it
is a story of an immigrant coming to
America and with all the stuff going on
with Trump and everything yeah this kind
of got a message of of how immigrants do
love America yes why they want to come
here yeah yeah yeah now we're your
family were they immigrants here yeah I
was an immigrant here i was i was born
in Iran and then when we were sitting I
was six years old is around the time
when the iranian revolution happened
okay so as the protests were going on in
the streets my father was in New York on
business and then he sent for my mother
to bring me and my sister over the our
winter holiday to stay with him for a
couple weeks and the idea was that we'd
stay a couple weeks and we thought that
the protest would would die down then we
go back yeah but they didn't die down
wow they just got worse and worse and I
always say like it's like we we packed
for two weeks but we stayed for whatever
39 38 years Wow and we had and my baby
brother was back in Iran and we had to
get him out a little after we had left
just because we thought we're gonna go
back wow that's crazy man your parents
must be so strong yeah I mean I think a
lot of a lot of immigrants man it's like
they come from wars and revolution yeah
and that's why they're so hardcore you
know it's like they first of all they're
used to the cultures there are so not
the culture that we have in America
which the culture in America is go in
the backyard and play catch with your
son yeah tell your wife you love her
yeah go see your therapist and get it
out of your you know fright you'll get
it out so easy so easy to talk about it
yeah but a lot of immigrant cultures and
it's probably closer to what like maybe
the 50s were in America whereas I can
keep it in you have don't tell anybody
about your problems you know yeah that's
so very East Coast thing yeah it's
nobody's business nobody's business just
suck it up put on a brave face once in a
while hit your wife it's okay you know
drink drink to put the drink that's it
sounds like a bright Ernst pissed for
some reason like develop a drinking
problem yeah develop a drinking problem
keep it down you know to keep it inside
of you um and don't and you know and
your kids are there to just be like
patted on the head and give him twenty
bucks once a while ago play and then
just you know you do your thing so
you're not a lot of parent interaction
i'm guessing when you're a little bad
there was it was an interesting pair
interaction cuz like first of all my mom
was probably with us a lot cuz she's
probably driving us to go shopping i
hated going shopping with my mom i was
thinking about that today I saw a little
kid hating it dude the worst I hated it
I used to hide from my mom um I can
totally I can totally commiserate for
that right way and I would wait into the
wood Stephen and Mark Simone please
report to the snack bar to meet your
mother and I'd be like yes we're getting
pretzels absolutely do is just take off
I'd rather not I'm not doing it yeah
well my mom would actually I would it
was the reverse my mom would be like I'm
just gonna go in this department here
and she's like sheep so I'd be playing
him you know not paying attention yeah
look up she's missing that's a scary
thought when you're a kid so I I said to
go to the to the cashier be like I'm my
mom's missing and they'll be like can
the lady whose kid is looking she show
up Philly I was just over there trying
on bras but when you're a kid you're
like I don't know you're scared you're
scared as hell and so that was my
interaction with my mom was like a lot
of her a lot of it was her I kind of see
with my wife now it's kind of like her
just having to deal with these kids and
it's it's exhausting i was just gonna
that was the word i was gonna choose it
has to be exhaust exhausting so she was
kind of like frustrated with us a lot
like you know and she'd my mom my wife
doesn't hear our kids but my mom you say
hit us back old school old school with
hangers and stuff it's crazy man but it
was part of it was it was all part of it
cuz we were messing around and like not
you know it was it's she was on her um
um last what was the term on my last
straw it was a master all yeah and so
she that's that's how she was kind of
functioning and then my dad was this
real um magnanimous larger-than-life guy
he'd always be like with his friends and
stuff but when we come home very nice to
us and like act I was giving us cash
that's great I never felt like I needed
any I've to this day I've never felt
like I ever have
needed or struggled for for money Wow I
think he kind of instilled that
confidence in us that's great even when
I was in college in like you know making
little whatever peanut butter jelly
sandwiches and eating pasta with ketchup
because I was trying to do it on my own
yes I still always felt like no matter
what happens money's always gonna be
there and it wasn't cuz I was like oh my
father will bail me out is just I felt
like I will find a way well it's funny I
remember thinking back to my favorite
Maz Jobrani memories and amber once back
when I was managing the comedy store and
you gave me great advice because I did
not want to be a manager The Comedy
Store I wanted to be a comic yeah but
then you were asking you were like I
believe maybe were you working in
advertising at the time is that what I'm
early in my career I this is like 16
years ago yes probably right right yes
but yeah and you were like okay well you
have to get a job you are like you have
to you have to make sure your bills are
paid then then you would laid out this
unbelievable plan for me and I was like
that's really what I should do and I'm
just starving and working the door at
the comedy store this phone whatever I
do remember that you're like no you need
to make sure that your bases are covered
and you do this and there's plenty of
time at night or do you want to be a
writer or you could take a writing class
at like The Groundlings you could do
that you could do this but you have to
have the money coming in to make sure
that you could do all this absolutely as
funny because I had that conversation
with the Richard at the comedy magic
club I love that guy and he said he goes
I'd say the same thing too because I
tell them you know make sure that you
are getting the rent paid yes cuz then
that will allow you to do what you want
to do right it's weird people come out
here literally with stars in their eyes
yeah and I think there's a special type
of crazy that's attracted to Los Angeles
yeah we're just like nope this is gonna
happen yeah and like I look back at the
last 15 years and I'm like I was really
blinded for a long time yeah miss equate
life goes on man you have to pay your
bills yeah yeah yeahs care of yourself
that take here and I think it puts you
in a better frame of mind when you've
got that it's like it's it's horrible to
be you know hungry and trying to write
jokes it's terrible it's not funny it
gets dark at a certain point yeah you're
sure so I I always tell people I go you
know have something like I early on I
had that day job and so that's when I
started actually I'd been I did plays
when I was a kid and
in junior high school and I was a big
fan of Murphy's and I wanted to be like
Eddie Murphy how do you remember the
first time you saw Eddie Murphy I think
I was like in the 10 range because I've
gone back to look at it so I was born in
72 and i think was like 8082 i always
look at when his movie started coming
out and was right around there yet
trading places i think was like what 82
something like that and i think he was
on SNL like an 80 or 81 right around
there yes I'm pretty sure that's when I
discovered him and it's my fact a great
thing I just saw the day this this shows
you like how much this guy meant to me
because it's like that Eddie that I knew
then as a kid you know how it is like
you you probably have like kids come up
to sometimes when you do stand-up that's
great and they've got these this Liz
look in their eyes and you just like why
just get so nervous yes we realize
you're a big deal to them yeah and so
Eddie Murphy was huge already but then
he was such a big deal to me that just a
couple weeks ago I just I'd done at
headlined the Melrose improv and I done
I done to shows and it was good night
then I came home and I should be I
should have gone to sleep i was tired
but I but whose because princess
principal just passed away like a couple
weeks before that and my wife had been
watching that bit where Charlie Murphy
tells a story of you know the the the
basketball star basketball story that
they do on Chappelle yeah so I was like
let me find that I want to watch it is i
like have a tea at the end of the night
because i had like i had a sore throat
let me have a tea relax and I'm doing
that I don't always do that I often have
tequila or something but it was a tea so
I was a during the t looking for the
Charlie Murphy been in every bit that
was on YouTube was someone recording it
on their TV wow I was like Africa to
forgive forget and then I look and at
the bottom it says Eddie Murphy at the
comic strip and I was like what's this
we got to check it out someone has
uploaded Eddie Murphy I think in like 80
maybe 89 at the comic strip it's the
craziest thing to watch cuz he's he's
done it he's not a pop in Wow he doesn't
pop in and so it's kind of grainy
material but it's like but it's clear at
certain points but then it gets granny a
little bit but he does a lot of crowd
work Wow which is amazing to watch yeah
because you're like oh my god that's
what we do now yeah and then
um a lot of the stuff from delirious
he's I think working it out cuz so I
because some of the just a lot of it's
already done but some of it is close to
being done you can see it because I'm 90
somewhat % sure that this is before he
did delirious that's incredible because
in my lifetime that's to me the greatest
special I've ever seen with ya arias
yeah I I've seen pieces of the one prior
recorded in Long Beach yeah then that's
when Eddie Murphy says is the greatest
piece of stand-up ever recorded oh wow
gotta watch it again yep I can't find it
well I am I I got that box set the prior
head and I started listening to that
when i first started and my audio
recording of that is another one of my
mazda brian i remember you talking about
priors boxset yeah yeah so I remember
because I was when I was at the ad
agency and remember i had to this is
this like the kind of stuff you do i was
an assistant at the ad agency and so i
had to drive this was one so i had my
day job and I would do stand-up at night
and then we had some like we're pitching
something that we have to go to
Sacramento for and I was an assistant so
they were like you bring up all of the
all of the boards that we've made you
know we had these huge boards that were
part of the presentation mm-hmm they're
like you could drive that up so i was
driving eight hours to whatever six
hours of sacramento so i got that box
set and i just put it in oh wow that's
great dude it your your road trip goes
so much faster when you have stand-up
comedy you just listen to it oh my god
it was great that's when I rediscovered
Richard Pryor and that was early in my
stand-up career and that's when I
realized for me I love what Pryor was
doing just because of the social
commentary and some analytical stuff
yeah you know and that's kind of who I
would if I would if I could emulate
anybody it would be somebody like that
and that's why to this day I still try
to put some political stuff or social
stuff in my act yeah because I feel like
we can like like it is as a comedian you
can you can you can get some points
across oh we do whether we choose to or
not yeah like some people I think it's
there almost they're wasting their
opportunity like for me I'm not a very
political guy but because I don't want
to take part in anything that divides
people yeah I just want to bring
everybody together yeah and remind that
we're all lovable yeah
we're all deserving of love but that's
message I want to put out every night
you have that opportunity because we do
affect audiences yes out a doubt
precision is interesting you say that
because it took me about 16 17 years of
doing this till I found out I realized
it's okay to alienate some people and
i'll tell you why shore because of that
you're you're saying you're your point
is to bring people together so that will
automatically alienate yellow that make
sense yeah i don't want to hear it
because my point I realize that a
certain point is I'm very liberal just
liberal that's why I am so for the
longest time and to this day when i get
up in front of an audience that i knows
conservative mm-hmm I'm like should I go
there should I talk about my liberal
points or not and so more recently I
have been saying bah bah bah yeah I'm
very liberal you know I'm pro-gay
marriage and I'm pro-immigrant and I'm
pro all this stuff right and and I
realized that is helping me i'm 44 years
old i'm a grown man I should have my own
opinion sure I shouldn't be deterred by
someone in the audience was gonna get
offended if I do a joke about Trump
because they're hardcore conservative
and they're gonna give said about that
well here's the thing i think as a comic
voice this is the sort of path I was
like all right I'm at a point my career
where nobody knows who I am they're
coming out to see comedy yeah but the
people that like my brand of comedy
they're gonna bring their friends next
time then there's gonna be people that
are like not for me yeah and cool I want
to get rid of that not to get rid of
them I mean though you're right bottle
them through yeah and it's like the
quote the little group of fans that I
have like from the podcast or little bit
they're the sweetest kindest people they
bring me drawings they bring their whole
family yeah they know I'm the type of
act where they can bring her kid yeah
they could bring the grandmother yeah
and it's like there's nothing caustic
about it yeah and I'm like yeah that
that's who I want that under my tent
that's who you're attracting is perfect
yeah like I've had I was doing a show at
the Laugh Factory recently and I think I
was doing some jokes about Trump or
something and and there was this guy in
the audience and I could you tell he's
kind of getting bothered I he was in the
back I think they were I don't know who
they were but they they they were
probably more conservative than liberal
and as supposedly as he was walking out
Randy the doorman there was like heck I
came out he's like god I don't like I
don't like that too much is too much
to political too much pot I don't like
politics and just interesting to me how
some people it's like like they don't
they want to they want to avoid life is
politics I mean that's just what we're
in and so if I if the fact that some
people say I don't like pot like I don't
like politics on my comedy that's what
they say a lot of times I don't pause in
my say well you know what that's the
guy's point of view that's the
comedian's point of view I understand if
you don't like my comedy that's fine but
it's just interesting how some people
will be waiting for certain words or
certain opinions that will just turn
them off a hundred percent mm-hmm like I
could have done if I'd done if I'd done
like 10 minutes of jokes about I don't
know about trees right and the guys like
okay this is good you knows I'm loving
this guy and then I get him Trump and
he's like I'm not like I love comedy so
much I loved one like somebody like Joe
Rogan will bring up a point of view that
is so different from mine but it buckles
me with laughter does that make sense
exactly like I think that to me is one
of my favorite kinds of comedy and like
some of my favorite comedians take such
a different approach than I do like I
love watching Holtzman yeah absolutely
like oh this is great it's not what I
like to do yeah but I appreciate and
love the craft so much yeah and funny
listen you know what it's funny so like
I always say like even during the Iraq
warm the Bush administration like if
somebody did a joke about bush that was
funny whether you supported him or not
you should laugh absolutely and
unfortunately some people don't have
that yeah the convictions aren't strong
enough conviction and I think that they
just they ultimately they they they're
sensitive to certain topics this has
happened to me on the most random thing
like a lot of Iranians like so when I do
shows I'd say if I'm headlining there's
probably like fifty percent of the crowd
is Iranian and the rest is other right
but some iranians are very sensitive and
they think that by doing an accent of my
mother or by you know saying that like
in Iran we had you know a bad economy or
something that I am exposing like the
negative side of Iranians to Americans
okay I really that crazy it's a really
that crazy um so I was doing a bit just
I was just an Oklahoma the other night
yeah so
and it was sponsored by an Iranian
organization and it was a mixed audience
but I got to this bit about car seats
and how as a parent I was I do a lot of
parents stuff and I say has a parent now
like in America were so sensitive to
this stuff like you put your kid in a
car seat til they're 35 years old you
know but I go in Iran I go when I was a
kid we didn't have like we have car
seats I go I was always in the we'd have
seatbelts and its true like yeah we'd be
in style seventies and it just wasn't
just Iran it was the rest of the world
but some lady in the back was like no
way we had it seventy years ago we had
to call car seats was like what she like
seven years she started yelling I go I
don't even understand what you're saying
70 years ago she was no 70 years I go
can somebody tell me what she's saying
that's almost like she's saying 17 years
ago I was like 17 years ago and then it
was just the funniest back and forth
there's a certain point I go lady I go I
talked about politics I have my kids I
talk about all this other stuff and you
take offense at the car seat bit and
somebody after her son came up
afterwards I was like I'm so sorry my
mother does stuff like that ah but just
like some people like she was in the
back listening to me talk about how
there was no car seats in Iran when that
what metro and she was like this guy is
bad-mouthing Iran you cross the line of
God people are so sensitive and they're
so judgmental right now so stupid I'm
sorry it's just that's not sensitive
it's stupid it really is because it all
I know honesty it's like first of all
everyone can everyone can comment on
everything now because of like it used
to be before the the social media yeah
if you if you really want to go out and
complain about something yet to put an
effort in yeah it to go to staples buy
some paper NAB home start writing that
letter yeah get upset crumble it up
throw it out think your opinion out
think you're pinning out maybe if you
start cutting the letters out of a
newspaper to put it down I mail it go
wait for two weeks hopefully they answer
you right now everyone just goes and
puts the opinion and it's crazy because
look some opinions I've had people email
me before and say listen man I was at
your show and I'm a fan ba bah blah you
said this thing I'm not sure if you know
I didn't take it the right way and when
they come to me like that I usually take
my time to explain to them and I go
listen and I appreciate you coming out
and really what I meant with that like I
used to do a joke where I made fun of
the media coverage
for the Boston bombing mm-hmm because
the media coverage was such that there
was two Moroccan guys with backpacks on
standing at the finish line and the New
York Post took their picture and put it
on the cover of their pay paper and it
said bag men indicating that those were
the guys but it turned out they weren't
the guys it was just two Arab looking
dudes with the backpacks who were big
marathon fans who happen to be at the
end of the mirror probably at snacks in
their backpacks leveah but I was making
fun of that with some I've had a couple
people come to my shows and see me do
the bits about it and they're like
Boston Marathon was a tragedy you
shouldn't joke about it and I go I'm not
joking about the Boston Marathon I'm
joking about the media coverage and by
the way I start that whole bit by
talking about how I was in Boston a week
before it happened this is true yeah and
how my first thought was that my heart
went out to the victims I was
heartbroken I really was and then I go
my second thought was just please don't
be a Middle Eastern please don't me
Middle Eastern and then I go into the
bit but so people you know if they come
at me with some kind of comment like
that I tend to take a second to explain
to them right but the problem I have is
sometimes like I've especially with this
movie night with the trailer again
Iranians being sensitive okay so in the
trailer people can watch it online
basically it shows at the beginning this
guy wins the green card lottery and he's
so excited that he starts waving the
American flag in the streets of Iran as
they're waving the flag somebody tickles
them the flag falls on the ground he
picks it up he keeps waving it we showed
that it actually fell into some oil okay
there's a guy played by Peter the
Persian who's down the street fixing his
car he looks back he doesn't like
wouldnae these people chanting and
dancing so he takes a cigarette of his
mouth flicks it it goes backwards hits
the flag flags on fire okay so now my
character who's this bumbling idiot kind
of Inspector Clouseau time right he's
got a burning flag America flying out I
think it's a whole different kind so he
throws another guys are stepping on the
fight to put the fire out and then
people bring out the cameras but in a
bit and then it flashes quickly to what
we is our version of Fox News which is
Cox news uh-huh and the guys like we
just found this online this guy's a
jihadist buh-buh-buh-buh-buh so it's
totally a mislead right yes but we try
to make fun of Fox News we're trying to
make fun of this guy's situation but
I've had some iranians calm
on my page just by seeing the streets of
Iran and in all honesty the streets of
went when we were filming it uh-huh
we're trying to replicate the streets of
Iran or do you feel my butt would fill
the downtown LA okay and our production
designer we have an independent film
your kind of limited so if you have a if
you if you have a big budget film you
have a long time to see the oh yeah you
know oh that's what it looks like okay
let's get this so we were talking to the
production designer the whole time
leading up to that shoot going listen
here's some pictures from the streets of
Iran we found on internet on the
internet you know it's pretty
cosmopolitan make sure you get that we
show up to shoot it and me my co-writer
and my co-producer all three of us are
on our Iranian American okay and we
should have to shoot it and we look more
like oh my god this looks like a bizarre
and Morocco but this guy got it wrong so
we go over like dude what happened he's
like no this is kind of what I could put
together on the oh my god now we have no
money to like we don't we can't change
it okay let's just shoot from an angle
that doesn't show the vendors too much
[__] it down a documentary behind the
scenes absolutely been just as funny as
the food because with us what we got and
the tude what else go as soon as we knew
that it looked like Morocco gonna get
some crap from Iran is on this well of
course when the when the trailer goes
online I've had some irani be are you
there's this movie disparaging of
Iranians because you're not representing
the Iran Iran the way it is and I'm like
dude we've gotten our asses kicked so
much in American cinema the past 40
years yeah this is definitely a step in
the opposite direction have you seen the
iron sheik yeah i mean the port Abboud
yeah with that tough as a kid watching
the iron sheik i think it was just like
it was entertainment you know I I just
saw his entertainment but we didn't have
like I was a big fan of all the Italian
movies because that was the closest I
felt to like somebody who kind of look
like me yeah yeah yeahs mob stuff yeah
but it's just funny how people would
judge you know talking about like just
people like I said people are stupid
because they come on the judge based on
something very small yeah and I go see
the whole movie first number one number
two you know what you don't like it go
make your own movie yeah you're saying
yeah because it took a lot of effort and
really the under the the underlying
theme of my movie is to show Iranians in
a fun silly light and by the way the
hero of the movie is an Iranian it's
like in an American movie like you don't
have that one was that ever before they
don't get it oh so sad some my people
are just so lost I was saying I wish
there were a thing called twit slap
where you could slap somebody I'm
starting to come with the point of view
like I'm very sweet guy and I want
everybody to get up but I'm starting be
like hey I'm offended that you're
offended how about that oh yeah how
about my opinions mmm how about that
well that's my point listen the point is
this an I'm a sweet guy you know we I'm
a nice person you're the best IRA John
Caparulo wants years and years ago I was
like ah nobody hates my I just for
whatever reason to I just have that like
I've certain images I'm just an I mean
there's no reason to be a jerk so I was
a nice guy as are you you're one of the
nicest people I know and it's like and
that's the problem is when somebody
criticizes you then you realize exactly
we just said you realize wait a minute
I'm a grown adult I have I pay rent I
pay mortgage what it's like I pit you
know I have I'm no longer a kid cuz I
grew up thinking like it to be
respectful yes they have an opinion they
just I'm so sorry I'm younger than you I
probably don't know what I'm talking
about you're probably an expert cuz
you're older taking a wait a minute I am
an expert have 17 18 years now yeah and
you're coming at me with your criticism
of my comedy so you know what it's not
for you it's not for you I don't want
yeah that's it that you don't have to
like everything man not everything's for
you the whole it's like you like what
you like and enjoy it and as a matter of
fact Facebook's made it very easy you
just unlike yeah that's all you got to
do that's it yeah it's crazy but it but
people just feel so self-righteous and
they think they know listen everyone can
express their opinions but it's just
like as it as an artist it's like it
because listen we we probably are very
sensitive to comments I won't put out
youtube videos because of that that's
how I was just like I can't deal with it
i don't need some thirteen year old and
des moines pooping on my journey news i
early on I had that when I first like
mmm own YouTube was like again a right
around the time we were doing actually
evil came out on Comedy Central 2007
that's when YouTube was starting to
really pick up yeah and I remember
seeing it for the first time was like oh
my god this is great and I read the
first comment like this guy rocks I'm
like vintage yeah this is this connects
was like this guy is the best thing ever
I'm great another third goes like this
guy sucks like what the hell that's the
worst and then they get an argument the
one guys like you're an idiot you're an
ad I'm a kick oh my god yeah what at
please it's just for the and it's gotten
out to a whole other level so you really
got ignored
I see you got ignored I still get reeled
in sometimes I don't look oh yeah well
the reason I started looking and maybe I
should just stop in general is because
in all honesty like when you post
something you you I look to see if like
somebody hits me back and goes where can
I get tickets or like you know right
coming to bubble blood I'm like oh this
is another opportunity to promote yeah
thats enough thats an exhausting uh
exercise yeah like social media has made
the job of a comedian 24-7 absolutely
where it's just like ooh because I I try
to engage thank everybody that reaches
out to me like you're taking time out of
your schedule to thank me for something
I'm going to thank you back but then
it's like it never ends because then
they shoot you another message Bab
solutely then it's like oh my god do it
just doesn't stop I have many
conversations going like that and I try
to like tone it down by going smiley
face yeah yeah and then they come back
they come back with where you been man
I'm talking about could you imagine if
you were 12 and you could have you could
interact with Eddie Murphy on Twitter
you know I mean he actually would send
it's like the coolest thing ever for
somebody's it is amazing right you
brought up earlier that you the video
the movie has a Iranian a hero like
growing up that I don't think a lot of
white people really understand is not
seeing yourself portrayed in movies yeah
what is did what was your experience
watching like a rainy movies as a kid
and with that yeah that's the thing like
I grew up watching American movies right
I mean I I you know we didn't have any
iranian movies I mean by my parents and
stuff they might have had some stuff
laying around i might maybe I caught it
here and there a little bit in college
but you know a lot of your first of all
Iranian cinema is amazing like they they
want a lot of those international awards
like the Khan awards and stuff so when
you watch those they're all very serious
there's a lot of symbolism I also don't
think a lot of Americans know how how
beautiful an advanced of a culture
Iranian culture is and especially before
the Revolution like how friendly it was
to the west and how I mean it's it's
weird how our media tries to manipulate
people's perceptions of other human
beings absolutely i believe and bourdain
data parts unknown in iran and he when
he went there he said they were the most
hospitable people
met and there's a lot of Iranians that
are very modern they're very advanced I
mean you go if you if you went to Iran
right now I think you you would
experience like this bustling city is
not is not like like Saudi Arabia's a
lot more clamped down yeah Iran is a lot
more open in that way cool but but still
the regardless like there's good people
everywhere absent and so the cinemas
amazing like a few years ago there's a
great movie was called a separation and
the they won the Best Foreign Film and
the Oscar category but it was a serious
movie and it was amazing i was just
riveted watching it for two hours and
they're so so yeah growing up there
wasn't a lot of Iranians like the
depiction of Iranians and movies where I
think in but I think down and out in
Beverly Hills the neighbors were Iranian
I forget like what they did but they
were like usually if he showed an
Iranian in an American movie it'd be
kind of this like brooding dad who like
you know or it was it was like sometimes
I was like they did have them i think is
like terrorists and stuff like that it
never it never was never wasn't me
watching and going like oh wow this is
that silly guy does a guy can get behind
yeah you know it was always like okay
all right and to this day I mean you
just haven't seen it I mean we had the
Prince of Persia which was Jake
Gyllenhaal I didn't go see it yeah that
was based on a video game but you know
like I said it's like every culture
every community has several different
people types of people you have you know
you have the the guy's a doctor you got
the guy who's you know a deli store
owner yeah and those stories aren't told
unless you tell those stories oh that's
a great point you're saying like his
heart of it there's no one right now
sitting at a studio right now going you
know what we should do we should do that
movie about that that nice guy that nice
Iranian guy who owns the deli that we go
to eat at all the time and do a movie
around that guy right that's not gonna
happen yeah until his son becomes a
writer and goes dad I'm gonna write your
story yes I'm saying yeah I never
thought about it like that yeah yeah so
that gets back to more or less an
obligation of the artist to impact their
world you have to create to do it
no one else that's gotta make the
criticism even harder because it's like
hey man like you're this kid you come
here when you're six years old you're
getting exposed to American humor i do
want to try to get into that a little
bit cuz i think that's so cool you're
already doing plays and stuff like that
you come up this character almost 20
years ago and then all the work it took
to bring this thing to life you did
everything it sounds like you wrote it
you're down with to see everything raise
the money for it you're selling people
year in advance you're not tell parties
right and then one random person doesn't
get it and then they I don't like the
way the trailer looked yeah that's like
did you understand the bigger picture
here what I'm trying to but that's why
you gotta like that's my issue like you
were talk about how you like to make
everybody happy everything I'm a little
bit like that too but I've learned a
little bit of like okay you know what my
issue is I gotta let that go I got to
realize what you just said this person
could be there could be a
thirteen-year-old kid it could be some
grown lady who's got her own issues it
could be a million things I generally
have come to this as I've lived more
life we treat other people the way we
feel about ourselves I totally totally
believe that yeah so the people I get
offended by what you say the people that
don't get it there's something going on
in their life or ultimately they need a
hug and it's very difficult it's usually
the people that need to hug the most
that deserve it the least yes that makes
absolutely no you're right you're
absolutely and it's funny because you
know we don't know where they're coming
from and they have their own opinion and
and they may even even if they saw the
movie they still may not get what you're
trying to do right so you know that's
the beauty of art like I remember one of
the one of the lightbulb moments for me
was I was watching Letterman and he was
like he goes yeah they just put Wi-Fi in
Central Park which is great cuz it last
time I can take my laptop down there and
read all my hate mail I was like oh my
God he's getting hey mail lady gaga like
Kevin Hart has got millions of fans you
know how many people probably like
probably like on his page you know
bad-mouthing him yeah and that comes
from a lot of stuff i remember Katt
Williams did a funny bit about like
haters and how like people there's
always gonna be people that hate yeah
that's just it's just a fact and also
the beauty of it is the other thing
that's good to know is the more hate
mail you're getting the better know
you're becoming dice had told me that a
long time ago yeah he said it was the
pay he was like it's the people that
hate you
yeah you're like oh wow I've got to the
point now where there's people that are
not liking what I'm doing that's
fantastic that means I'm out there
because if you are really if you're if
I'm somebody who I'm not at all an
abrasive person and I like to be liked
like you yeah but but if you were to be
liked by everybody you're doing
something wrong the it's just too you're
not you know you're not putting an
opinion into this no and what I'm
noticing as I've evolved as a comic the
people that like me love me and the
people that don't it's not for me and
I'm like good good because it's not for
everybody and you want those people at
your party that are going to love you
and are going to be into and get you
like I when I post I've been posting as
the character Jimmy vest with a lot on
Instagram and Facebook awesome so it's
great because the people the Chi go and
read the comments and most the comments
are people to get it yeah and their land
they're enjoying it and they get my type
of humor yeah like I just did a post
from him for Mother's Day oh and again
he's kind of a bumbling it he kind of
doesn't get everything yeah so I just
have them quoting all these like things
where I like basically I'm like you know
I'm like you know today is Mother's Day
so we need to remember that our mothers
are the ones who give us life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness and I'm
like you know and then I said something
like what I say also so today ask not
what your mother is gonna do for you but
what you are gonna do for your mother
okay to be a mother or not to be a
mother that is the question so I just
did all these solaris and so the people
that are fans were like watching their
I'm gonna they're loving it and I'm sure
somebody were like what yeah but it's
like that's my sense of humor did you
see that's but that's what's perfect
like I know I can I get in front of I
call them the cool kids they don't they
don't they don't like what I do oh yeah
the cook the cool kids are like two is
that you're too cool for school I hate
it when people like a like nah man this
is an edgy enough this isn't it you know
what good for you go be all edgy
miserable somewhere i'll go be miserable
somewhere else really it really is yeah
seriously i did i did a show in seattle
a couple years goes great show the
neptune theatre i love the neptune
theatre it's a beautiful place we had a
rock and roll show it was me a mere k
and this guy name is patel out of New
York just a fun everyone had their own
Island you know I'm here's a little
edgier nimish is actually very animus
just wrote for Chris Rock he's great
writer great night got a little like
after party across the street after was
having some drinks and there's this guy
we just had a problem like he was just
this young guy like mid 20s who just was
like I don't know what he thought if he
thought like my stuff was too vanilla or
if he thought it was like derivative or
so that's the other thing when they
think you're derivative of somebody and
you like who and then like they'll name
somebody go I've been doing it like that
I've been doing before leg longer than
that person so sad when people are
always looking for something not to
enjoy yeah it's like you're living wrong
man yeah they're always looking for like
wow this is what's wrong dude let's
celebrate what's right this guy was so
this guy was so just angry i mean his
cousin or somebody was there with him
and she was like a she was a fan it's
really a great time and then this guy
was like this guy supposedly played
soccer something i'm a big fan of soccer
yeah ice play soccer so we started
talking about soccer or something and
somehow i came up and he was kind of
being a little critical and then i was
trying to give him props i was like i'm
sure like you know you're probably
really good like you know did you ever
try to make it like in the MLS or
whatever and he was kind of bad-mouthing
the MLS like nah it yeah and I was like
wait be around people like that and I'm
like what is your problem i could dude
I'm trying to give you like some props
and now you're saying you're better than
the MLS now you're saying you're better
than I know you have you have a
psychological issue here yeah and I
really got upset and in one point one
point i got like probably had a couple
drinks too yeah but i was like i got i
got all like I was like I was like I
this is what I do and I'm damned I'm
like real i buy cussin yeah like I'm
damn good at it whatever they say
another stuff yeah cuz I'm a bad mom for
Papa but I got in his face yeah and they
were like a calm down I was like no this
dude's it yeah me calm down you come
yeah yeah I got there I got all pissed
if you were like calm down okay I gotta
relax this guy's got issues you should
see a psychiatrist not me yeah but that
that's exactly what it is too you're
absolutely right that's what it is the
guys got don't know what his problems
are because we we are we are functioning
under the impression that all the people
around us are at that at the same sanity
level as us we all have issues of course
but we think that everyone around us has
the same level of sanity but no I mean
oh you don't have to be saying that come
to a comedy club no right you have you
have you could be you know depressed you
could be you could be just like you
could be out of your mind you'll be
whatever it is 20 bucks you buy the
ticket you show up now afterwards you've
hadn't you had an issue with a joke or
something so that you know it's like we
have to remind ourselves because we're
sensitive yes we got to run ourselves
you know what man let it go yeah um this
is just like I've had a couple times
where I'll be looking at those quote the
comments under like one of my posts
again I'm really looking to just see if
someone's asking a question of where
you're gonna be or whatever or saying
good job and I want to say thank you
like you sure and then you run across
that one and I've had a couple times
where I was like I was just about to
answer and I go you know what give it 24
hours I give it 24 hours and I forgot
about it yeah cuz the throttle when I
left what you just said we're so cooked
to our social media and our phones and
all this stuff that suddenly I mean I
know there's like comments on my pages
have become topics of conversation
between my wife and I mm whereas like it
should be we should be talking about us
we should know about my kids that about
our life yeah those two go like you know
somebody said Bubba blood today oh yeah
I know you know literally when you step
back from you go white why do I care
about this I don't care about this I
don't care I don't care about this yeah
it feels good just saying it get it out
I don't care about this people did you
hear that if you post something online
just put it out there somebody comments
I don't care about this yeah it's also
like I wanted to do a bit on it where
I'm like I've never seen a negative you
to comment that was like it's just not
for me I appreciate what you do but
that's just not my cup of tea like
there's no positive yeah pport just so
self-absorbed a for everything's for
that that's funny do it you're right
that is a that is a good bit it's just
not for me you do you know I really
enjoyed it's kind of like when you have
judges on any of these like I had to
judge on a comedy competition at the
Laugh Factory mm-hmm and everybody was
very nice like it was me it was a Marlin
way no Shawn Wayans Shawn Wayans um and
it was Richard Lewis I think Paul
Rodriguez is like four or five of us and
I was sitting there going one who's
going to be the Simon Cowell
of this group right nobody everything
even when there was comedians that
weren't good every one of us you got
good stage presence find something yeah
you hold that Mike really way got a good
head I like your shoes like is just keep
working at it hilarious was it temper
you as a kid because I was bullied as a
kid and when your kid you can kind of
separate yourself from it like you just
not friends with them so you're not
gonna hang out with them if they bully
you and it seems like with the eight
less social media there's no way to
escape it so it's like and it's also
kind of new so it's the older you got
the less teasing matter sure and the
more experienced that you have a social
media the less that you kind of care
about it so would like and like it just
it seems like we're kind of growing like
growing up with social media even though
we're older or adults now would seal
it's still it kind of jabs at you in the
same place where like the teasing jabbed
at you it's gotta be tough for kids man
I a friend of mine was telling me that
he's got daughter daughter in like
junior high and how the half a how mean
they can be to each other like they'll
be they'll be making plans and then
suddenly they'll leave one of them out
but it's all in social media uh and it's
just like it's gotta be hard cuz i mean
we're adults and we're getting affected
by this yeah much less a teenager you
know saying um you know the bullying i
got as a kid was just you know you'd get
it on a playground but they couldn't
follow you home and yeah it's true post
it on your page or something yeah you
know there's to get over you fight or
you get it whatever yeah there's
something to be said about like just
disengaging with it all mm-hmm you know
saying just gonna lay and if I was not a
comedian yeah I wouldn't be on a name
and then actually living your life yeah
like looking at people as you walk
around it's great it's crazy yeah I've
gotten back to especially with this as
the movies coming out in the crunch time
I've been gotten back into like driving
and texting which is really bad yeah
it's bad so I really need to like put my
phone in the glove compartment mm-hmm so
it's not around yep that's the way to go
absolutely because that's like your
office man like number one it's not safe
to text and drive a hundred percent no I
just did a benefit for somebody I don't
want to go into the TV bad but it's also
like it's a constant source of
distraction and stress like stress and
anxiety because it's like little silly
things that you feel like can't wait
but they can of course and here's the
thing when i started to post less on
social media people like the your little
online community goes through a little
withdrawal but then every life goes on
like I'm too busy too busy to keep on
doing this podcast every week hopefully
I get through May will do an episode
every every week in June awesome but
it's like I can't interact with
everybody on social media and and write
a TV show and write a script and do all
my own travel and get out on the road
it's just like yes too much though
there's been times when I posted
something that like got such an
overwhelming reaction that I exactly we
just said I realize I go wait a minute i
can't i can't respond to everybody this
now so that's just did like another post
going thanks to everybody for their
comments that's it I got nothing else to
tell you yeah that's all you can do
that's all you can do boy Lee what time
we looking at cuz I'm Maz is busy he's
like a real guests the it's three
o'clock we've done almost an hour okay
what do you want I can I get whatever
Road well alright what just do one like
random little kid question or sure that
you said I know you played soccer you're
still a fan yeah is there any coach from
your childhood through you played until
you still play everyone said I pick up
games but yeah I played I would like you
know played seriously in high school and
then I played a little bit like I tried
out for the team in college but I didn't
make it you know you went like Berkeley
or something yeah yeah yeah yeah no you
asking is there coach yeah was there any
like Coach were like you know that was a
good guy or that was a funny guy well
there's a couple of them there's this
one guy I Sam still in touch with him
from time to time because he somehow
found one of my one of my best friends
uh um Jesse they got in touch he was he
was on the team with me Jesse and I were
on the team together mhm and then he got
in touch with his old co the old coach
found him and then we and then he found
me so this guy his name was Fernando
Rodriguez great and he's a Mexican guy I
think he's mexican i'm pretty sure is
mexican haha and he was a fireman in
marin county cool and he was kind of
this macho dude kind of had like his
hair was a little bit below like above
his shoulders but he was kind of a he's
kind of a ladies man uh-huh it was very
funny because it was great coach we love
the guy he was such a nice guy we had a
really good team how old are you guys we
were this was soft
you're like 15 16 off the best time yeah
and uh this guy would bring like he
would date these like hot aerobics
instructors that's a tease and also yes
great and he would bring it to like two
times he brought two different really
hot aerobic instructor with everybody
like oh my god and he brought to her
them to like help us train so he was
like okay today you know guys today
we're gonna have you know whatever Mandy
she's gonna give you that she would run
us through some aerobics and we're like
you dog all right and all the kids were
like I want to be in the front row
because she was so hot it was so fun man
he was great and then my other coach
there Tom Ryan who was our junior and
high senior and senior year coach this
guy was just fit redhead always had a
baseball cap and he was just great like
it was just it was such a doz were such
great years because it really felt
serious like it really was yes we had a
good team yeah we want I think we won
all three of those years we want our
like our league whoa and yeah I was a
big deal we actually went to like the
norcal championships two years in a row
and lost those but it just felt like you
were in the best shape of your life you
know I think we would probably they had
a game or practice every day of the week
five days a week and and it was just in
these coaches were just really there
were really cool people like it was like
they even though they were grownups yeah
they treated us with a lot of respect
and I was you know and it was given back
I think that's a great life lesson that
right there yeah I remember that like
season two Sopranos I think we're Tony
Soprano goes those who want respect give
respect like that yeah so true yeah
absolutely man and it doesn't matter how
old you are like you really gotta you
really I think even the younger the
younger people you should give it to
them oh absolutely yeah yeah little kids
know when you're talking down to them
and they and then they know when you're
really listening yeah it's the truth
yeah absolutely man and I've learned
another great life lesson people live up
to the expectations you set for them so
the more you see the best in somebody
and the more love you give them the more
you'll get back yes like for sure yeah
buddy I can't thank you enough for being
honest thanks for having me man what's
the West Jimmy vest would
site again Jimmy vest vidcom so j IM my
vie EST VOD calm Jimmy vest food.com
movie opens Friday the 13th in LA and
see no irvine in washington DC friday
20th in new york and toronto and then
29th is just one night in San Francisco
but that's when it opens but we're
hoping people go see it opening weekend
so we can expand from there yeah that
would be awesome yeah and I Matt Maz
Jobrani on all that social media stuff
so if you want to send me some criticism
what was our line we came up with who
cares who cares exactly who cares yeah
dopamine somewhere else all right buddy
I love you thanks so much for hanging
thanks TV
look back at all the theories too
guys that was Maz Jobrani and once again
he came on to promote his new movie
Jimmy vest would so it's j IM my VES t.v
ood calm and good times is brought to
you by the Don Carlos taco shop located
in beautiful la jolla california
domingos Italian deli it's Little Italy
located in part of the San Fernando
Valley right on Ventura Boulevard in
Encino the best sandwiches ever or at
domingos and then my brother if you live
near philly you need a dentist check out
Chester County dental arts and then uh
Mike pies company freak fr EK wa re calm
they have all kinds of cool stuff on
there and you can see pictures of my
buddy Robert he's got its own line of
shirts on their team obrist and you can
use the promo code l.i.v.e IG and save
fifteen percent right we just did it
like real grown ups knock it all out and
then those shirts are comfortable I'm
wearing one now oh like look at that wow
that's a new one yeah isn't one it's
cool cause like black on black almost
that's yeah it's cool that's awesome
mm-hmm are you ready I'm pumped up for
the the appreciations yeah what he got
ok I'm happy I uh that I got to talk to
my uncle that I haven't got to speak to
in probably close to a year oh that's
awesome i'm happy that i went on the Bob
and Tom radio show and had so much fun
and guess what what happened they gave
me free flowers to give my mom that's
not like part of a promo and my mom
loved them so I got my mom a card
flowers and a gift I'm thankful that I
was able to find a good local florist
when my mom lives this is like the 3rd
or 4th holiday in a row that you get
your mom flowers and stay low she's
loved them every time awesome it's hard
so it's good to find especially a lot of
places now you do like the 1-800 flower
and those they'll get the way they're
weird or they send the wrong order so a
local florists just like domingos or or
like some all businesses man's important
it's the best let's see what else would
be a good 10 ready for this I'm so
grateful that I i was in Indianapolis
but guess what I got to eat what do you
get to eat giordano's chicago style
pizza
what did you get if there's a giordano's
they're starting to franchise and they
had one in indy just just out of the
blue good luck yes that's a minute I was
just walking so I got to eat an Italian
beef sandwich and giordano's pizza in
the same day same meal well kinda i have
one slice because i got a bigger pie and
then I ate it so I have one slice at
lunch one at dinner cuz it's so heavy
Chicago style and then I was so excited
I want to do anything after the show cuz
I know what pizza back in my room so
then after the shows i came back ate
pizza and there were still two slices
the next morning for breakfast yes do
you have for meals out of it did he play
in the breakfast 1 i'll do that sometime
yeah i have pizza mike i'll save some
for breakfast yeah cuz there was a
fridge and a microwave so it was perfect
well that's the best I'm grateful that I
get to go home and Joe in June oh that's
awesome I'm grateful that I'm gonna be
on re season three of our a show that's
amazing yeah very grateful I'm grateful
there and I got to meet Andrew Dice Clay
last week oh he's the best I love him he
was so not he was super nice to me and
it was a it was like I don't know the
podcasting has been so fun but there's
everywhere everyone asks which episodes
stand out and that one is gonna be in
temperature right oh my god hey find him
an element Eleanor together Eleanor
Eleanor come on oh yeah yeah ah that's
great there they it's funny just they
have so much time with each other and so
much chemistry that they're amazing I'm
podcast together yeah they that's a good
good good good comedy couple right there
oh yeah let's see oh I'm so grateful for
all the people that came out to my shows
like that drove that far they brought me
a cake shake Payton's picture the
cheesecake there's a lot of cool stuff a
lot of laughs I've been so grateful for
this podcast because the people that
like it are fun people to hang out what
yeah then when I have they bring you
shakes and then pictures yeah because
that's like kind of thing like ma's and
I we sort of touched on a little bit but
I'm so grateful that the type of comedy
that I do appeals to the type of people
I really like absolutely i'll be stinky
if you didn't like your friends or the
people come under your fee i wouldn't be
able to do that now
I'm grateful that a Paula finish law
school last week oh that's awesome I'm
grateful for the major league baseball
package I really am because my phillies
I they're playing so great right now but
they're so young I don't know their
names are they really playing great yeah
they're like five games over 500 or
something Wow yeah I think they have
like the fifth best record in baseball I
didn't know that yeah they're playing
great pitching there's this kid out of
the bullpen that's been lights out he
have one blown save out of like 12 or 13
opportunities just because he had
pitched like two games in a row already
okay well that's awesome yeah awesome
they're winning all these one-run games
are a really fun team to watch I'm
grateful that I got to um I got to go
spend some time with a and on and uncle
out here like there's been a lot of
family ah that's creating fun I'm
grateful that my buddy fluff he's gonna
play The Comedy Store tonight he's got
me open up for him dad's gonna be crazy
I was so happy just to have Gabe come
back to the comedy store cuz it's like
my two families you know what I mean I'm
like hey buddy comedies was really fun
too and then at the Chi told The Comedy
Store i said my buddy gable and they're
like whatever he wants to do whatever
whatever giver wants to do will let him
do I'm grateful and this is going back a
little bit but then I got to go to his
Christmas party with you and oh yeah
that I'm grateful for that too that was
awesome that was awesome plus like I got
to watch you and Joey just really not
enjoy a magician yeah magic scares you
were just thinking about it'll make me
laugh just like yeah I don't like match
hope you enjoy like mmm yeah nervous I
don't like it in it in that and that
will always make me laugh just you and
anyone just a little bit uncomfortable
but I'm grateful that on Wednesday I'm
gonna get to see my buddy William on my
little buddy Steven that's gonna be fun
mm-hmm I'm grateful that I'm grateful
that I get to hang out with you on an
unexpected that in expect this was great
I'm very thankful grateful for this oh
here's a good one yeah it's one of my
cheat codes for life I just went bought
new socks it's the best it's like
walking around on a cloud
it's one of the cheapest best ways to
make yourself feel good I completely
agree but i'm not a sock person
personally I'm grateful that I have I
just did my laundry and I have all clean
underwear because clean clean underwear
to me asked I might switch it out twice
a day sometimes is even when I didn't
work out but now that I'm working out
fresh underwear is I couldn't agree more
is vast it's the little things I'm
grateful for the website price built me
and all the people that amazon link that
that that helps man so all you guys had
are using that have gone awesome Steve
calm and click through the link to buy
stuff on Amazon grateful absolutely I'm
grateful that someone clean my apartment
this week you Paula clean my apartment
for me that's awesome when I was out of
the house one day so it was great I'm
grateful I got a picture of my little
buddy Angelo in the suit remember I said
last week or two weeks ago that the
website guys ad suits calm and they
hooked up my little buddy at the
hospital with a suit for his
confirmation if you learn yay looked he
looked awesome in it ah there's
something but about little guys in Lydia
look ahead I just imagine like hey at
least he was like fresh to that he
looked great I'm grateful that I got to
have a good workout this morning and
actually enjoy because I was looking at
some pictures of how big I used to be
you know blood debt never even thought I
was that big so I wasn't thankful that I
was able to and happily or no yet Lee
looks so much yuva how much weight have
you lost I still about 90 pounds I'm
fluctuate wow that's incredible it's
good um my goal is to get to that
hundred pound mark but I'm how can we
help start making food delicious maybe
we could get back into the habit of like
going on a walk or so I'm going to the
gym maybe we can hike one day a week
yeah my my issue I'm grateful that I've
been able to work out more I've been
enjoying that a lot but my issues with
my diet right now so I'll try I'm
working and that's its kind of the
frustrating part is when you're working
out and you don't see any results that's
when you get go on you're like oh yeah I
gotta figure out where
I'm grateful that I have so many people
around me that want to help and can help
me with my diet and and get me where I
want to be that's awesome yeah I'm very
grateful that I can walk to the gym
that's awesome am grateful that my body
works you know yeah oh my god so
grateful that's a yeah that your body
works that you're not in pain mm-hmm
that is just uh something and they don't
even think about it now grateful for all
the friends that I have to I can't wait
to just hang out tonight haven't been to
the comedy store in a while it's I mean
I was there last week but it seems like
forever ago so I can't wait for that who
are you looking forward to seeing like
any specific people I like city I love
going there i love i love when you don't
know you're gonna run into it's gonna be
so fun to see Gabe there and his whole
crew like Martine and Alfred I mean
they're just all great dudes that'll be
so fun but then I really like the door
guys at the comedy store and that open
mic kid like the guys trying to break
into the club mm-hmm they're my favorite
they're so cute and tonight's the open
light too right hmm yeah it's a fun like
the Hangout you get a like nostalgic on
Mondays showing about all the open mics
you didn't you yeah absolutely I'm I'm
grateful that I get to see all this
great comedy speaking of comedy in LA
I've been blessed over the past four or
five years to get to see moresee soil oh
yeah we are spoiled and you know what
this just dawned on me like I I remember
one of the fur the first night I managed
the comedy store like Mitzi shore
herself I had to go to her house and
pick her up and she had she walked me
through the club and showed me
everything the way she wanted it and the
show we sat in and watch that i was
called arabian nights and it was her
version of a show of primarily Arabic
Arab American comics that she had
hand-picked and she told me because she
this is like a year before September 11
she was like God told me there's going
to be a lot of healing that needs to
take place you know
ann arbor Vince Vaughn got up on stage
that night mas got up on stage that
night I met a mad Aron Kader it was
really cool cold like memory to go back
and have cuz now we had Ma's on the show
you know yeah and it just dawned on me
when you were talking about comedy and I
was thinking about how much i love the
comedy store and how busy I've been
lately I'm so grateful that I never gave
up I'm so grateful that I just never
said okay I can't do anymore how close
do you think you got oh I did here's the
thing like there were times I definitely
gave up but I just couldn't do anything
about it I know where else to go and
there's nothing I could do you know what
I mean like I would mentally give up but
didn't give up does that make sense like
sometimes I would say forget it in my
brain but still keep on doing it right
because you had to pay the bills or yeah
but I was like deep down I knew I
couldn't stop I wanted to give up right
but I never did I never really did and
I'm for that I'm forever grateful that's
beautiful man I think that's a perfect
way that's great yep so whoever you are
out there whatever you're dealing with
one of my favorite quotes ever was from
this televangelist this guy named Robert
Schuller it was awesome used to do this
TV show called the hour of power and he
had this one of his great quotes was
tough times don't last but tough people
do that's beautiful yeah and it's like
just never give up guys I love you thank
you so much for listening take care and
god bless
ha
you
such an easy
well
you